this is a production of Cornell
University
feeding of the leaf hopper damages the
shoot tip and causes this is called a
witch's broom where the lateral shoots
are starting to form because the apical
shoot is very damaged
this is beagle and this severely reduces
yield and here's some more damage on
yarn same kind of thing going on because
it's chlorosis and necrosis of the
leaves
[Music]
[Music]
types of pillows
[Music]
very susceptible bride
Tulley a champion and a pretty resistant
variety which is 9 400 6 and this is a
choice experiment to see if
if given a choice we poppers are feeding
on all three plants or if they're only
feeding on
in the choice feeding experiment there
were three different treatments for the
low and high potato leafhopper
treatments I released 20 and 100 adult
potato leaf hoppers respectively into
each cage after 24 days I compared the
relative growth rate of each treated
willow genotype to a control that was
not exposed to potato leaf hoppers as
you can see in this chart when the
potato leaf hoppers were allowed to feed
freely on the three different willow
genotypes within the cages there were
significant differences in their
relative growth rates the susceptibility
of these willow genotypes to the potato
leaf hoppers was consistent with what we
have observed in the field with djor
being most susceptible 9 400 6 most
resistant and telly champion falling
somewhere in between this type of
feeding assay proves to be a helpful
tool when trying to compare the
resistance to potato leaf hoppers among
willow cultivars under controlled
conditions but still I wondered whether
the 9 400 6 willows continued to grow
well in the choice experiment simply
because the leaf hoppers preferentially
fed on other genotypes of willow and not
on 9 400 6 or whether they did feed on 9
400 6 but is somehow resistant to the
effects of feeding to find the answer to
this question I also conducted a no
choice experiment in which 100 adult
potato leaf hoppers were trapped inside
of cages and forced to feed on chutes of
resistant cultivars for 17 days again I
used Tully champion 9 400 six and a
third potato leaf hopper resistant
cultivar called Preble we've never
observed potato leaf hopper damage on
these cultivars in the field so it was
surprising to find that we saw potato
leaf hopper damaged and significantly
reduced chute growth under the no choice
treatment conditions compared to a
control that was not exposed to potato
leaf hoppers based on these results I
concluded that for at least these willow
cultivars resistance to potato leaf
hoppers is caused by the
leafhoppers preferentially feeding on
certain types of willows and avoiding
others we don't know exactly which
willow traits deter the potato leaf
hoppers but our breeding program
continues to capitalize on these
resistant traits in order to breed
cultivars that can thrive under a wide
variety of pests and environmental
conditions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu